hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and i am absolutely
thrilled to be with part of the cast of
the sandman and maybe one of the people
involved in bringing this amazing comic
series graphic novel to life i'm just i
have to start with what is it actually
like as a creator as a showrunner to
try and bring one of the greatest
graphic novels of all time to life
talk a little bit about that
it was uh terrifying but then you know
you get the chance to actually work with
neil gaiman one on one
um who's been my hero since the first
issue i read of sandman and he was so
open and so collaborative and so loving
and coming from good omens he really
understood what what work needed to be
done to
bring it to life on screen and so he
really approached it in an inclusive and
collaborative way
and gave uh me and the writers for
season one um permission to really
reimagine um
uh
well it what we tried to do was really
take the book and expand it so
any scene that we imagined that he had
he'd not been able to put in the comic
we were able to imagine fully and then
and then bring neil in on it and and
give the audience more hopefully of what
they loved so it was a gift uh i've seen
the first three episodes they're what we
call let me think real good um
i definitely want to know
what is it like for actors
being involved in something that is so
beloved by and i know there's a little
generic but i'm actually being very
sincere
this material means so much to so many
people
and i mean just so many and what is it
like as actors taking on the
responsibility of these roles knowing
like
so many people around the planet really
effing care
i i think there's
there's a high that comes along with
that
pressure
that if i fail at this it's going to be
really bad but if we win
it's going to be a huge win and i think
that's just the excitement that
makes a lot of people
want to act and get out there and do in
front of a lot of people
um and it just goes to say about the
source material how wonderful it is
i feel like this has just been aching
like you know people have been aching
for it for like 30 years like it's so
striking and unique the the comic book
so to finally get that
brought to live action i feel like it's
more you know instead of the
instead of the kind of nervousness and
anticipation like i personally feel
coming in and sneaking around the sets
and looking at the production design and
seeing what can
you know creatively it's such a unique
world so getting to to see that come to
life i kind of just feel
buzzed and like thrilled and excited
yeah i mean we can only
[Music]
the the creative team behind this was
really great and you know everyone put
their hearts into this and so many
people you know on the production team
were fans of it and we can only hope
that we did a good job
and i think that because neil is just
part of every aspect of this he's all
over it it's still his voice it's still
what he wanted it to be so that for me
as an actor anyway it made me feel
really secure
in what i was doing in the world that we
were creating and you've got allen's
incredible script so it's like you just
exciting
a bit of pressure but super exciting
yeah so i don't want to do any spoilers
as i asked the other group i'm going to
ask you the same question you guys have
10 episodes in the first season
which of the 10 was your favorite or
which of the 10 are you most looking
forward to the audience seeing
i think the buzz around town is episode
5 is quite good
however i'm not in that
so it's not
episode 9 for me was um just a
treat of how they actually pulled off
the convention
and the type of characters that were
there
if that's
just enough
episode 9 is great
um i'm most anticipating eight and nine
um
just simply the same as boyd said just
you know seeing all of the fantastical
things that happen at the convention
um i'd genuinely say it's really hard to
pick because i've watched all of them
and i think i cried in everyone um
because they're just such different and
human stories but i think for me episode
five
dinah yes
yes so many thoughts and feelings going
on for me watching that and it's
beautiful it's stunning to act visually
it's incredible so i'm really excited to
see that i'm gonna back it with five
some david thula slove going on here um
yeah i'm going to back it for five and i
and the visual images of looking at
desire in that red pvc like room it
looks amazing so i look forward to
seeing that in particular
um i
episode the the diner episode 24 hours
was the one i was sort of dreading
because it's such an iconic issue and i
didn't know how we were going to do it
on tv
and it ended up being my favorite uh of
all the episodes just the experience of
it we shot it like a play we built that
diner we got to rehearse it in a way
that we couldn't because of kovid so it
was a really special episode and our
director jimmy childs did an incredible
job so i have a huge
soft spot because i feel like that's
where we figured out how to make the
sandman tv show was episode five from a
behind-the-scenes standpoint i have to
wrap it just real fast i'm gonna ask one
last thing we're at comic-con and
like everyone here loves to geek out
about something i don't know if you were
able to walk the convention floor but if
you could what's the thing that you
would totally go and buy and geek out
over
oh well uh anything at the sideshow
booth i'm a huge huge sideshow
premium format figure collector so i was
i was glocking at some of those yeah
uh anything anime related
just
like anything i don't know if they had
anything from um
i don't know if they had any one piece
things but definitely just i'm a huge
stranger things fan
love stranger things so yeah
i'm gonna go broad i like like old like
vintage i need like old vintage posters
and scripts and things like that broad
um
my son who's four is having the time of
his life he's doing a couple costume
changes and spider-man and power rangers
so
i think seeing him light up like this is
really special everything you guys
mentioned by the way is on the
convention floor listen i have a million
other questions and they are already
giving me the hook i am just going to
say i really really cannot wait to watch
the rest of it i hope it's a massive hit
and you guys get to keep going and i
just want to say thank you for coming in
thank you so much thank you